>>> SO AN OMINOUS WARNING
TONIGHT OM THE HEAD OF THE CDC
IN THE WAKE OF THE SUPREME COURT
DRAFT OPINION THAT WOULD
OVERTURN ROE V. WADE,
DR. ROCHELLE WALENSKY SAYING SHE
BELIEVES WOMEN MAY DIE IF
THEY'RE DENIED ACCESS TO
ABORTION SERVICES, ESPECIALLY
WOMEN WHO DO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO CROSS STATE LINES
IF ABORTION IS OUTLAWED IN MANY
STATES.
WE HAVE A LOT TO DISCUSS NOW
WITH CNN SENIOR POLITICAL
ANALYST, KIRSTEN POWERS, AND
ALICE STEWART, A REPUBLICAN
STRATEGIST.
I SAW SOMETHING YOU TWEETED AND
I WANT TO READ IT.
YOU SAID, BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
IT'S POSSIBLE TO BELIEVE
ABORTION IS WRONG AND NOT
SOMETHING YOU WOULD DO AND
RECOGNIZE THAT REASONABLE PEOPLE
OF GOOD FAITH DISAGREE AND
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO FOLLOW
THEIR OWN CONSCIENCE.
TALK TO ME ABOUT THIS.
>> YEAH, WELL, I WAS ADDRESSING
THE FACT THAT WHEN I CAME OUT
WITH MY OPINIONS ABOUT THE
LEAKED DECISION I SUPPORT ROE V.
WADE AND I ALWAYS HAVE, YOU
KNOW, A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
COMING AT ME BASICALLY, YOU
KNOW, MAKING RELIGIOUS ARGUMENTS
BECAUSE I'M CATHOLIC, AND SO I
WAS ADDRESSING THIS ARGUMENT
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE MAKE THAT
YOU, YOU KNOW, IF YOU'RE A
CHRISTIAN, FOR EXAMPLE, OR A
DECENT HUMAN BEING, TOUGH SEE
THIS IS A CHILD BEING MURDERED
AND SLAUGHTERED AND ALL THE
LANGUAGE THEY USE.
I WAS TRYING TO MAKE THE POINT
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THIS IN A
LESS BINARY WAY, WHICH PEOPLE
HAVE SUCH A HARD TIME DOING,
THAT PEOPLE OF GOOD FAITH WHO
ACTUALLY SPENT A LOT OF TIME
THINKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE HAVE
COME TO A DIFFERENT CONCLUSION,
AND IT'S MADE IN GOOD FAITH, AND
YOU KNOW, YOU ARE FREE TO HAVE
YOUR OPINION ABOUT IT, BUT TO
TAKE YOUR OPINION AND THEN
IMPOSE THAT RELIGIOUS BELIEF ON
TO OTHER PEOPLE, I JUST, IT'S
NOT OKAY.
AND SO THAT WAS THE ARGUMENT I
WAS MAKING, YOU'RE FREE TO
BELIEVE WHAT YOU WANT TO BELIEVE
AND LIVE YOUR LIFE THAT WAY, BUT
ONCE YOU START MOVING INTO
MAKING YOUR RELIGIOUS ARGUMENT,
YOU KNOW, THAT ANYBODY WHO
DOESN'T HOLD IT IS SOMEHOW SOME
KIND OF MONSTER, I THINK YOU'RE
IN SOME PRETTY BAD TERRITORY.
>> ALICE, I KNOW YOU ARE PRO
LIFE, AND YOU SAY THAT YOUR
ENTIRE VOTE FOR TRUMP IS
VINDICATED BASED ON THE SUPREME
COURT, WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE TO
WHAT KIRSTEN JUST SAID.
>> LOOK, I HAVE ALSO BEEN HIT
FROM MANY SIDES FOR SPEAKING OUT
MY OPINION ON THIS VERY DIVISIVE
ISSUE.
I LIKE AM PRO LIFE, AND I HAPPEN
TO BELIEVE --
>> I'M NOT PRO LIFE.
>> I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO PROTECT THE SANCTITY OF THE
UNBORN AND PROTECT THE LIFE OF
INNOCENT CHILDREN.
THERE ARE 63 MILLION REASONS WHY
I BELIEVE THIS BECAUSE THAT IS
THE NUMBER OF ABORTIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN CONDUCTED SINCE ROE V.
WADE WAS ENACTED IN 1973, AND
LOOK, THESE ARE THE PEOPLE,
THESE UNBORN BABIES DON'T HAVE
SOMEONE SPEAKING OUT FOR THEM,
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE KEEP THEM IN
MIND AND SOMEONE STAND UP FOR
THEM.
AND LOOK, PEOPLE HAVE LIT THEIR
HAIR ON FIRE WITH THIS OPINION
COMING OUT SAYING THAT ABORTION
IS GOING TO BE BANNED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
WHAT THIS DOES, THIS TAKES THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE, TAKES IT
OUT OF THE HANDS OF NINE
UNELECTED JUSTICES AND PUTS IT
IN THE HANDS OF ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES AT THE STATE
LEVEL, CLOSEST TO THE PEOPLE
WHERE THE BEST DECISIONS ARE
MADE, AND THAT IS IMPORTANT TO
KEEP THAT IN MIND.
LOOK, REPUBLICANS HAVE FOUGHT
FOR DECADES FOR ORIGINALIST
JURISTS TO THE SUPREME COURT
THAT WOULD ADHERE TO THE STRICT
INTERPRETATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT ALITO DID IN
THIS OPINION SAYING THAT
ABORTION IS NOT SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSED IN THE CONSTITUTION,
THEREFORE ROE V. WADE WAS
INCORRECT FROM ITS VERY
INCEPTION, EVEN RUTH BADER
GINSBURG SAID JUST THE SAME WHEN
SHE ADDRESSED THE LAW COURT
YEARS AGO.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> THE OTHER THING THAT I SAID
TODAY IS THIS ARGUMENT IS LIKE
PEAK PATRIARCHY.
IT'S A SELF-REINFORCING LOOP
THAT YOU CAN NEVER GET OUT OF
BECAUSE THE MEN WHO WROTE THE
CONSTITUTION HUNDREDS OF YEARS
AGO DIDN'T THINK THAT THE PEOPLE
WHO THEY BELIEVED WERE THEIR
PROPERTY, RIGHT, THAT WOMEN WERE
THEIR PROPERTY, THAT THEY DIDN'T
BELIEVE THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
THEIR PROPERTY SHOULD HAVE A
RIGHT TO ABORTION OR TO FRANKLY
ANYTHING IS IRRELEVANT.
YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T -- WE DON'T
LOOK TO THE HISTORY TO MIMIC,
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE
THAT WOMEN AND BLACK PEOPLE WERE
THEIR PROPERTY.
OKAY.
WE LOOK TO OUR PAST TO LEARN
LESSONS.
AND TO HAVE JUSTICE ALITO OR
EVEN TO LISTEN TO YOU, ALICE,
FRANKLY SAY THAT BECAUSE THESE
PEOPLE DIDN'T PUT ABORTION IN
THE CONSTITUTION THAT THAT MEANS
THAT THERE IS NO RIGHT TO
CONSTITUTION, IT'S CRAZY MAKING.
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE THERE'S NO WAY
TO EVER GET OUT OF THAT LOOP
BECAUSE THIS IDEA OF EVEN OF THE
TEST THAT HE'S PUTTING ON IT,
YOU KNOW, NOTHING REALLY CAN
PASS THESE TESTS.
>> LET ME ASK YOU THIS -- THERE
ARE OTHER ISSUES BEYOND
CHRISTIANITY WHERE PEOPLE FIND
SACRED, RIGHT, AND SHOULD
THAT -- IF PEOPLE WERE WANTING
TO ESPOUSE THEIR RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS OR PUT THEIR RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS ON THE COURTS OR MAKE
THEM LEGAL, ALICE, WOULD YOU BE
OKAY WITH THAT?
THERE ARE MANY RELIGIONS THAT
DON'T LIKE MEAT.
SHOULD WE BAN MEAT IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE.
I KNOW IT'S NOT EQUAL, BUT HOW
FAR DO WE TAKE THIS, IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE A SEPARATION OF
CHURCH AND STATE, AND I
UNDERSTAND YOUR FEELINGS ABOUT
IT, AND I ACCEPT THAT.
I UNDERSTAND KYRSTEN YOUR
FEELINGS ABOUT THAT AND I ACCEPT
THAT.
SHOULDN'T THERE BE A SEPARATION
OF CHURCH AND STATE AND WHEN YOU
HAVE SOMETHING LIKE THIS,
SHOULDN'T IT BE BASED ON WHAT
THE DOCTOR AND WOMAN THINKS IS
OKAY RATHER THAN ON A RELIGIOUS
BELIEF BECAUSE PART OF THE
REASON, A MAIN PART OF THE
REASON THIS COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED
IS FOR RELIGIOUS FREEDOM.
>> WHAT NEEDS TO BE KEPT IN MIND
HERE IS THE FACT THAT THIS IS
ABOUT WHAT IS WRITTEN IN THE
CONSTITUTION, THIS IS WHAT THE
SUPREME COURT WITH THIS OPINION
ADDRESSES IS THIS ABORTION
ISSUE --
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT YOU UNDERSTAND THERE ARE
LOTS OF THINGS THAT WERE NOT
WRITTEN IN THE CONSTITUTION.
WHEN THE CONSTITUTION WAS
WRITTEN, I WASN'T CONSIDERED A
HUMAN BEING.
IT'S NOT IN THE CONSTITUTION.
DO WE GO BACK TO THAT TIME AND
SAY, YOU KNOW, FOR A PERSON OF
COLOR, A BLACK PERSON, THAT I
SHOULD NOT HAVE EVERY RIGHT THAT
YOU HAVE, ALICE, AS A PERSON
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION IN
AMERICA BECAUSE IT'S NOT
ORIGINALLY WRITTEN IN THE
CONSTITUTION?
>> LOOK --
>> THEY DIDN'T SAY INTERRACIAL
MARRIAGE WAS OKAY, AND THE
SUPREME COURT SAID IT WAS.
>> ALICE HOLD ON, JUST ANOTHER
POINT, UNDER THE CONSTITUTION,
YOU WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO VOTE,
AND NOW YOU HAVE FULL RIGHT AS A
MAN, AS A WHITE MAN, WHITE MEN
WERE ABLE TO VOTE.
NOW YOU'RE ABLE TO VOTE AS A
WOMAN, SHOULD YOU NOT BE ABLE TO
VOTE BECAUSE IT WASN'T IN THE
CONSTITUTION?
>> LOOK, ALITO SPECIFICALLY SAID
THIS OPINION DEALS SPECIFICALLY
WITH THE LIFE ISSUE, AND ALL OF
THOSE OTHER ISSUES -- MANY
PREVIOUS PRECEDENTS HAVE BEEN
OVERTURNED, PLESSY V. FERGUSON
IS A CASE IN POINT.
LOOK, TALKING ABOUT WHAT IS
CRAZY MAKING, WHAT'S CRAZY IS WE
HAVE SOME STATES, VIRGINIA, FOR
EXAMPLE, THAT ALLOWS ABORTION,
TAKING OF A LIFE UP TO THE THIRD
TRIMESTER.
I MEAN, THE MAYBE IS ALMOST BORN
AND THEY'RE FINE WITH ABORTING
IT.
>> BUT THAT'S WHERE THE COUNTRY
LIVES, IN THE MIDDLE.
IT'S NOT THE EXTREME.
>> SAVE A WOMAN'S RIGHT.
THIS IS INSANE.
>> HOLD ON, I'LL LET YOU MAKE A
POINT.
I THINK MOST OF THE COUNTRY
BELIEVES THERE SHOULD BE
RESTRICTIONS ON ABORTIONS, THE
LIFE OF A MOTHER SHOULD BE
INCLUDED IN THAT, THAT IT SHOULD
BE ALLOWED BUT THAT IS NOT WHAT
IS HAPPENING HERE.
GOING ON, SORRY, I'LL LET YOU
MAKE YOUR POINT.
>> THE VAST MAJORITY OF
ABORTIONS HAPPEN WITHIN THE
FIRST EIGHT WEEKS, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS ALWAYS TAKING US OFF
INTO THIS OTHER PART OF WHERE
IT'S DEALING WITH LIKE AN 1% OF
ABORTIONS.
IT'S NOT WHAT WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT.
I WANT TO GET BACK TO WHAT YOU
SAID, ALICE, AND THIS IS THE
POINT I WAS TRYING TO MAKE WITH
THE TWEET THAT DON BROUGHT UP,
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT -- YOU'RE
SPEAKING IN VERY DEFINITIVE
TERMS THAT THIS IS A PERSON,
THAT AN EMBRYO IS A PERSON, AND
WHAT I'M SAYING IS THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE OF GOOD FAITH WHO
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT.
REFORMED JEWS WHO HAVE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME THINKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE MORALLY AND THEOLOGICALLY
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT.
WHY IS THAT VIEW BEING IMPOSED
ON PEOPLE WHO DO NOT SHARE THAT
RELIGIOUS VIEW.
>> I GOT TO GO, ALICE, QUICKLY.
>> MANY PRO LIFE PEOPLE BELIEVE
LIFE BEGINS AT CONCEPTION.
>> GREAT, DON'T GET AN ABORTION.
>> AND ALSO TO THE POINT DON
SAYS IN TERMS OF MAKING
EXCEPTIONS, I BELIEVE THERE
SHOULD BE EXCEPTIONS IN THE CASE
OF RAPE, INCEST AND LIFE OF THE
MOTHER.
THIS IS NOT A BLANKET ACROSS THE
BOARD BAN ON ABORTIONS.